all right guys welcome back to the
channel Hill Creek Outdoors we're over
here trying to clear some of these trees
out um where we're going to put the
pasture and let me show you what we got
and how easy the John Deere 1025 loader
works out on this situation so we're up
here clearing the brush out and we had a
valve
stem actually pop off when the brush hit
it and it popped off so what we're going
to do is we're going
to pull the tire up new valve stem but
with the loader you don't even need a
jack let me show
[Music]
you all right so now we got the valve
stem replaced we're going to go ahead
and pump it up and she'll be ready to
roll don't forget to like And subscribe
till next time here on Hill Creek
Outdoors we'll see
you